This episode has been brought to you by the great courses. Plus.
I'm going to tell you some more about molybdenum wires and show you some
amazing micrographs pictures,
the lights of which I've never seen before.
So let me remind some of you that we did an experiment or Neil did
an experiment where he puts a high current through a piece of molybdenum
wire piece of horizontal molybdenum wire.
And amazingly at the end,
we got blobs of material all the way along the wire
separated very regularly.
And the first thing we had to do was to see whether this
experiment could be repeated.
So we did the experiment two or three times again,
and each time we got the same result.
Now, when we did it,
the first time I suggested that what was
happening was that we were forming liquid on the surface.
And that surface tension was separating the liquid into little droplets.
In fact, these droplets have a technical name,
which I learnt by looking at some papers, they're called undue Lloyds.
[Inaudible].
Our last video in which we showed you these until Lloyd's got people,
very excited and quite a number of viewers suggested in the
comments that we should try heating the wire in a vertical
position, because then if a liquid was being formed, it would run down.
So when somebody proposes a test like that,
you've got to try it.
You were right. Instead of getting regular blobs,
what's happened was the liquid formed and ran down.
We got a big globe at the bottom and the tiny one where
the Y had burned through.
[Inaudible].
It looked as if the regular Angie Lloyds were starting to form,
but then it didn't happen.
And the liquid ran down and formed one big blob at the bottom
and the way then broke.
And there was a small blowup left at the end of the broken way.
So I was really pleased because it confirmed my suggestion
that there was liquid,
but that raises quite a different problem,
which is why should there be liquid?
But the clue came when Neil took
one of these wires to our nanotechnology center and
there they can use electron microscope to take
images of the [inaudible] or the surface of the underline.
[Inaudible].
What came back was absolutely amazing.
One of the pictures.
My favorite one looks like an underwater coral reef,
particularly the feature in the middle has almost
perfect. Three fold symmetry. And with things coming off,
it's 120 degrees apart. I showed this to my colleague, Andre,
who said something almost as a throwaway remark,
which helped us solve the whole problem. He said,
could it be oxide rather than metal?
So then I began thinking, when you hit the buyer,
you would expect it to melt in the middle because the outside can lose heat.
So the center should be hotter,
but we were heating it in air.
So perhaps the surface of the metal was burning
and forming oxide.
Then of course it would be hotter on the outside because of the chemical
reaction.
So I looked at the melting point of molybdenum oxides,
both the oxides, molybdenum dioxide,
and molybdenum trioxide have melting points that are nearly a
thousand degrees lower than that, of molybdenum metal.
So what that means is if you form oxide,
it could melt way below the temperature at which the metal would melt.
So the metal would be solid and the liquid would be on top.
The other thing is that the density of the oxide
is about half that if the density of the metal.
So if you form the oxide,
you will get a bigger volume of liquid than the volume of the metal that you
burn.
So you get more liquid than you might expect just from melting.
And because the micrograph soap, the tip was all frothy.
It's probably gone even lower density, which is why they suddenly appear so big.
It turns out that droplets forming in a regular space
are quite a well-known phenomenon.
You see it in all sorts of circumstances. If you take a tap,
force it for the Americans and start water going quite
fast, and then gradually turn it off.
You will suddenly find the stream of liquid will break up into series of
droplets.
And this is just the same effect as we're seeing here with the wire.
Then of course, what we have to do is to test is it molybdenum oxide?
So with our new samples,
Neil went back to the nanotechnology center where as well as taking the
pictures,
they can do an elemental analysis on the electron
microscope. So you can look at different areas of the surface.
Hi, come in. Well,
what do we got? And lo and behold,
where there was one of these blobs,
the surface had oxygen in it, as well as molybdenum,
but where there were no blobs,
there was very little oxygen, not none, but very much less.
So the theory looked really quite good, but when you have a theory,
you need to test your theory or your hypothesis with a
prediction.
So I predicted that if we heated the way and the vacuum,
when there's no way as, so the molybdenum couldn't burn,
we shouldn't get the Angelos.
So Neil got one of his sophisticated vacuum
chambers with a window and we started heating the wire
and we got amazingly bright light sort of
super light about.
[Inaudible].
Super, super bro. I'm turning everything down on the camera.
I think Nick was impressed. He's going to go and get the, uh,
the device so we can measure that.
The way I got hotter and hotter and hotter,
but not to trace of Angela Lloyd.
And then when everything had cooled down the way instead
of being black was shiny, like you would expect to metal.
So not only did it,
so the oxygen was needed to form the Angelos,
but it also showed that oxygen was attacking the surface and making
oxide layers. So just heating it up,
drove off whatever muck there was on the surface and left a really nice clean
piece of molybdenum wire. Also when Neil opened the chamber,
there was clearly a very thin film that evaporated,
and you could tell it was thin because it had a rainbow of colors
and you get these colors by diffraction of light, by very thin films,
because it went to such a high temperature that molybdenum was
evaporating. It didn't have to boil because the pressure was low,
but some of the molybdenum vapor was coming off and it hit the cold surface and
condensed. The important message is that this experiment,
which began really as a fun experiment with a piece of molybdenum has not
only made this think and understand something about heating
wires and air that we hadn't really thought about before,
but it has given us these amazing pictures.
And my favorite one is free to download in the description
below.
So we've been going deep with our molybdenum wire,
but if you want to go deeper into the topics you love,
why not check out today's episode sponsor the great courses.
Plus they have world experts on all sorts of topics.
I'd be pretty happy here going from Apollo 11 to some baseball history,
but for all you chemistry fans, well,
you're more than catered for understanding the periodic table
chemistry and our universe.
There's a whopping 60 half hour lectures here have had some
organic chemistry, still not had enough.
There's even more chemistry for a free trial and access to the great courses.
Plus incredible library of educational gems, cross old topics,
go to the great courses. plus.com/periodic videos.
Get this stuff streaming on your TV, your tablet, laptop, phone apps,
all sorts that address again,
the great courses plus.com/periodic videos, a free trial,
and will let them know you came from here.